>> IT'S FRIDAY AND PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS GOING AFTER JOE BIDEN
OVER HIS LATEST CAMPAIGN
MISSTEP.
AFTER THE 2020 FRONT RUNNER HAD
A SLIP OF THE TONGUE IN IOWA.
>> THEY HAVE ADVANCED PLACEMENT
PROGRAMS.
WE HAVE A NOTION IF YOU ARE POOR
YOU CAN'T DO IT.
POOR KIDS ARE JUST AS TALENTED
AS WHITE KIDS, WEALTHY KIDS.
>> [APPLAUDING].
>> THINK ABOUT IT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> WELL, WELL, WELL.
>> VICE-PRESIDENT QUICKLY
CORRECTED LIMB
CORRECT E LIMB
CORRECT E
CORRECTED HIMSELF BUT THAT DID
NOT STOP PRESIDENT TRUMP FROM
TAKING A WHAT TYPE AT JOE BIDEN.
>> JOE IS NOT PLAYING WITH A
FULL DECK.
I SAW THAT.
I HAD A TELEVISION.
I SAW HIS COMMENT.
JOE BIDEN IS NOT PLAYING WITH A
FULL DECK.
THIS IS NOT SOMEBODY YOU COULD
HAVE AS YOUR PRESIDENT.
BUT IF HE GOT THE NOMINATION, I
WOULD BE THRILLED.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> OH MY GOD.
LET'S GET INTO THE SUPERFICIAL.
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN KNOWN TO
MIS-SPEAK FROM TIME TO TIME.
>> YOU THINK?
>> IT REALLY WAS A SLIPPERY
SLOPE.
HE GAINED HIS FOOTING AND GOT IT
RIGHT AND SAID WEALTHY KID.
>> YOU ARE REAL DANCING ON THIS
ONE?
>> I AM DANCING.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> YES, BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
HE PICKED HIS STEP UP.
>> HE ALWAYS CLICKS WITH BLACK
PEOPLE.
OBAMA WAS HIS EDUCATOR.
HE IS CLEAN.
WITH THE DEMOCRATS HAVING A
PROBLEM NOT WITH THE BLACK VOTE
BUT BLACK VOTERS SHOWING UP TO
THE POLLS, EVEN THOUGH THEY MAY
NOT VOTE FOR REPUBLICANS, THEY
MAY STAY AT HOME BECAUSE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS NOT DOING A
GOOD JOB TO GET THOSE VOTES.
I AM SORRY, IF THIS IS THE BEST
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO GO AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP IT WILL BE A SAD,
SAD DAY.
>> ISN'T IT TRUE JOE BIDEN HAS
BEEN ABLE TO HOLD THE HIGHEST
AMOUNT OF SUPPORT FROM
AFRICAN-AMERICANS?
>> HIS SUPPORT AMONG
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AFTER KAMALA
HARRIS WENT AFTER HIM IN THE
FIRST DEBATE.
HIS SUPPORT ALMOST DOUBLED.
KAMALA HARRIS, SHE HAD'S DOUBLE
DIGITS PERCENTAGE WITH BLACK
VOTES.
AFTER THAT INTERCHANGE, JOE
BIDEN'S SUPPORT WENT UP.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS ABOUT
TAKING ANYONE FOR GRANTED.
WE KNOW THAT BLACK VOTERS ARE
STILL WITH THE DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES.
I BELIEVE THAT JOE BIDEN WHEN HE
IS TALKING ABOUT EVERY CHILD
DESERVES A SHOT, HE SLIPPED.
MAYBE IN HIS MIND HE THOUGHT
WHITE.
BUT HE WAS TRYING TO SAY
WEALTHY.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU MAKE THAT
MISTAKE.
>> IF A REPUBLICAN DID THAT, HE
WOULD BE BARBECUED.
HIS GAFFES ARE NOT NEW.
IT'S NEW IF HE GETS THROUGH A
THOUGHT WITHOUT A GAFF.
OUR PRODUCER HAS AN INTERESTING
PIECE OF TAPE.
>> WE EXCUSE UNITY OVER DIVISION
AND SCIENCE OVER FICTION AND
TRUTH OVER FACTS.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THAT TO ME IS BETTER.
THIS IS THE BIGGEST FIGHT OF HIS
LIFE AND HE IS DOING IT IN HIS
8th DECADE.
I WAS IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY I
WOULD BE WORRIED.
THIS IS EARLY.
>> DO YOU REMEMBER HOW MANY
GAFFS PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE?
>> I DO.
WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH BIND, THE
PEOPLE WHO SUPPORTED PRESIDENT
TRUMP IT MADE THEM MORE ENDEARED
AND I THINK THAT'S HAPPENED FOR
BIDEN AS WELL.
>> HERE'S WHAT PEOPLE SHOULD
KNOW ABOUT JOE BIDEN.
HE HAS ONE OF THE BEST CIVIL
RIGHTS RECORD OF ANY POLITICIAN
RUNNING TODAY.
I SAY THAT WITH RESPECT FOR A
LOT OF PEOPLE INCLUDING BERNIE
SANDERS AND ELIZABETH WARREN AND
KAMALA HARRIS.
HE'S BEEN FIGHTING FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS.
I DON'T THINK THIS WILL HURT
HIM.
I THINK JOE BIDEN WILL BE
CAREFUL NEXT TIME.
>> DID BIDEN FREE A RAPPER?
>> JOE BIDEN YOU DROP A QUARTER
AND GAS COMES OUT.
HE WAS BARACK OBAMA WAS THE
FIRST BLACK MAN HE MET WHO WAS
ARTICULATE.
IF A REPUBLICAN SAID THAT IT
WOULD BE OVER.
DONALD TRUMP LOW
AFRICAN-AMERICAN AND LATINO
UNEMPLOYMENT.
HOLD ON.
DONALD TRUMP LOWERED FLAGS TO
HALF STAFF ON AUGUST 8th.
NUMBEROLOGY GUY SAYS THIS IS
TIED TO THE ARIAN BROTHERS.
>> MD-DNC?
>> WAS THAT A SLIP.
>> NO, THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
>> HOW IS THAT NOT A DOG
WHISTLE.
SAYING THEY ARE AS SMART AS THE
WHITE KIDS?
>> HE SAID POOR KIDS.
HE CORRECTED HIMSELF.
HE MISSPOKE.
WITHOUT JOE BIDEN WE WOULD NOT
HAVE ANYTHING TO TALK ABOUT ON
FRIDAY.
>> THE GAFFS OF TRUMP AND BIDEN.
TRUMP'S GAFFS DON'T SEEM
RELATEED TO AGE.
BIDEN IT MAKES HIM FEEL LIKE HE